[Música]
llegó el momento de hablar de salud en
directo américa de france 24 más romero
sala ya está conmigo en el estudio mar
bienvenida a feliz mañana viernes vamos
a hablar de un tema bien delicado el
suicidio un problema que cobra miles de
vidas de manera silenciosa más si raúl o
muy buenos días de manera silenciosa
porque a veces puede parecer
verdaderamente difícil hablar de estos
temas pero también creemos que es
nuestra responsabilidad
porque igual que muchas enfermedades del
suicidio y sus causas se pueden tratar y
se pueden prevenir vamos a repasar las
cifras generales según la oms cada año
se quitan la vida más de 700 mil
personas eso significa que el suicidio
responsable de una muerte de cada 100 en
todo el mundo son unas cifras parecidas
para hacernos una idea a las muertes
anuales por vih y sida para entender la
magnitud de un poco de este de este
fenómeno la región con las tasas más
altas desde áfrica aquí también ven a
europa y el sudeste asiático que son las
tres regiones con las tasas más altas de
suicidio en el mundo y también muy
importante destacar que a nivel global
es la cuarta causa de muerte en en
jóvenes entre los 15 y los 29 años pero
en algunos países como vamos a ver más
adelante es incluso la causa principal
también queremos recordar una frase de
la organización mundial de la salud de
las causas también de este del suicidio
y es destacar que las cosas son
múltiples por supuesto hay temas de
salud mental que recordamos se pueden
tratar se pueden acompañar y pues no son
una de las principales raíces del
suicidio pero también queremos destacar
como dice la organización mundial de la
salud que el conflicto el desastre la
violencia también la pobreza la
discriminación en todos sus aspectos son
unos de los factores más importantes
también a la hora de entender este
fenómeno que es el suicidio márquez que
sabemos de la prevención del suicidio
pues por suerte cada vez hay más planes
en más lugares del mundo en más países
para abordar este tema pero todavía
falta camino y para entender esto vamos
a viajar a españa un país donde en 2020
tres mil 941 personas se quitaron la
vida es la cifra más alta en 120 años
casi de registros en españa es la
primera causa de muerte entre los
jóvenes y pues el 10 de mayo se activó
una línea de atención telefónica para
ayudar a quienes están pensando en
suicidarse sólo en 24 horas
más de mil llamadas sin embargo hay
expertos organizaciones que dicen que no
es suficiente nos lo explica nuestra
corresponsal en madrid marina colorado
en este reportaje
cada día carmen dedica unos minutos a
escribir en esta libreta todos los
pensamientos que le ayudan en su proceso
de recuperación
amurallar el propio sufrimiento es
arriesgarte a que te demores desde el
interior
diagnóstico es un
trastorno de crecido ansioso recurrente
llegó desde los 16 años medicada en
españa la cifra de especialistas en
salud mental es muy inferior a la media
europea no puedes tener un intento de
suicidio que te den ahora para dentro de
3 y 6 meses o sea es que no puede ser
teléfono contra el suicidio dígame
algunos de los recursos que tienen las
personas con y de acciones o conductas
suicidas son las líneas de prevención
el gobierno español puso en marcha en
mayo de este año el único teléfono
público contra el suicidio hasta
entonces han sido iniciativas privadas
como ésta las que han suplido las
carencias estatales en un país en el que
cada día se quitan la vida 11 personas
es escalofriante y desde nuestro granito
de arena intentamos ayudar en la medida
de las posibilidades para que todo aquel
que esté desesperanzado y que quiera
ayuda nosotros cogemos el teléfono e
inmediatamente
ayudamos por cada persona que se quita
la vida otras 20 lo intentan las
organizaciones que luchan para frenar la
conducta suicida llevan años pidiéndole
al gobierno de españa' una estrategia
específica contra el suicidio piden el
mismo trato urgente que han tenido la
violencia de género o los accidentes de
tráfico
qué hacer a nivel de educación de
servicios sociales también de sanidad en
formación de profesionales en acceso a
medios letales en educación emocional en
cultura general sensibilización en
medios de comunicación todos coinciden
en la necesidad de hablar abiertamente
del suicidio para que deje de ser un
tabú y pese a las dificultades
carmen no duda en mandar un mensaje de
esperanza todos sacamos una fuerza luego
interior que te hace remontar el vuelo
como si fueras el ave fénix una fuerza
que hace que cada día se convierta en
una nueva hoja en blanco
y desde el periodismo y la comunicación
es decir nuestra rama cómo hacer cómo
contribuir para prevenir el suicidio sí
pues nosotros queríamos hablar de esto
cómo romper un poco una lanza a favor de
hablar de estos temas tanto con marina
con su reportaje como desde la sección
de salud porque realmente hablando de
ello es como también podemos empezar a
prevenir no a entender qué es un
fenómeno que pueda aceptar a muchas
personas en general durante mucho tiempo
ha reinado una especie de política de
silencio mediático porque se decía que
hablar del suicidio incitaba a las
personas que pudieran estar pensando
considerando en tomar esa opción y eso
es cierto si se trata pues de fenómenos
concretos aislados o si se trata el
suicidio de una forma también
sensacionalista pero tenemos que
entender que esto se trata de un
problema de salud pública y que hablar
de ello aparte de hacer lo visible y de
ponerlo sobre la mesa también puede
hacer que podamos ir a la raíz de estos
problemas por ejemplo como decía nuestra
compañera marina hablar de que faltan
profesionales de la salud mental en
españa- pero en muchos lugares del mundo
hablar de estas desigualdades que
también juegan un rol a la hora del
suicidio y sólo para terminar queremos
explicar que en la sección de salud en
la página web encontrarán unos datos
para líneas de prevención en américa
latina pues muchísimas gracias por esta
útil información también nosotros pues
pasamos ahora